welcome back to yet another tutorial in
Python by simply learn I am Anjali and
today we'll cover the concepts in
strings so before we begin let's look at
what exactly a string is now just like
you have integers floats byte and so on
string is a data type now what is this
datatype hold it holds a collection of
characters and when I say characters
that could include letters numbers and
even special characters such as space
period dollar add rate symbol and so on
now the syntax for storing a string is
much like that for any other variable
you have the variable name followed by
an equal to sign and the value of your
variable but in case of strings it's
important that you always put your
values within double or even single
codes so that is string at the very
basic let's start a demos and I'm sure
through the demos you'll have a better
understanding of how to use string and
where to use strings so let's start with
the most basic demo where we will store
a string within a variable and then
print the value of this variable so my
variable name is STG within which I'll
store the string simpler so I'll enter
the string within double quotes as you
can see here or I could also do this
within single quotes
like that and then in the very next line
I'll print the value of STG let's run
the code and as you can see here the
value is printed
now let me show a different value in STG
I want to store the string Tim's
birthday so I insert this within single
quotes Tim's birthday let me run the
program but here you see there's an
arrow
it says syntax error which is an invalid
syntax so if you come back to your
string you'll notice this is because our
string itself has a single quote so we
tried to enclose an entire string within
single quotes but what happened is when
the Python compiler encountered these
single code within the string it assumed
this to be the end of the string so STG
became equal to tim and the rest of the
word that is the s space and birthday
was just there for no reason and this
resulted in these syntax error so in a
case like this what you do if your
string contains within it a single quote
and close the string in double quotes
like this and now if you run your
program as you see Tim's birthday is
printed now in a similar manner if my
string has within it double quotes then
I'll store the entire string within
single quotes so let's say my string is
Tim's set I am busy today so since my
string has double quotes within it I'll
store it in single quotes enough string
is printed right now suppose Tim said I
am busy today that is I apostrophe M so
now in this case a string has both
single and double quote so here what we
can do is we can simply escape the
single quote here so for that you use
the slash and when you insert the slash
what it does is the character that just
follows the slash is taken as simply a
part of the string without any special
meaning
so the
compiler in this case sees this
apostrophe and ignores it for any
special meaning so if I print the string
now both my double and single quotes are
printed correctly let's try something
else out what if my string needs to be
of multiple lines so let's say my string
is here there and on the next line I am
typing welcome to simply learn so if I
try to do this in the similar manner
that we did for the other strings that
is insert the entire string within
double of single quotes as you see here
that does not work welcome to simply
learn is just not taken as a part of the
string even if I try single quotes let's
try that out
still no difference still our second
line of the string is not considered a
part of the entire string so here what
you do is you start and you begin your
string with three codes now these three
codes can be either three single or
three double quotes so if I am going
with silly codes I'll have three single
quotes here and three single quotes at
the end so in this manner you can have a
string with multiple lines let's print
this out too so we have a multiple line
string so now that we saw the various
ways in which you can store strings in
variables let's try out something new
now the first thing we look at right now
is this length function so the length
function is something that you'll come
across very often when you start
programming for the length function does
is it returns the length of your string
so if my string is say simply learn and
I want to print the length of STG
variable you just say print len off and
within the brackets enter your variable
name flin that so simply learn is of
length 11 what that means is that
eleven characters within it so even if
you have a space in between even that
will be counted as a character because
as I told you a string is a collection
of characters and this character could
be anything we print that out as you see
12 is the new length of your string now
just like in case of a DS even each
character of your string can be
extracted separately and again just like
in arrays this is done through the
indices so if I want the fifth character
of my string to be printed I can just
see print STG and just as the syntax is
an array the exact same way you have
your square brackets within which you
have your index number mentioned and
print that so a fifth character in the
string STG is I now remember the indices
in string to start from zero capital S
is at the 0th index I is at the first M
is at the second s and so on now if I
want to access every character of my
string one by one I can do this using a
for loop because as we learned
previously for loop is used to iterate
over a sequence and the string 2 is a
sequence it's a sequence of characters
so my counter variable is I for I in STG
and print I so I will iterate through
the string start from capital S and go
all the way up to N and every time you
are printing the value of I that is the
character that's holding at that
particular point of time so when I print
it as you see every character is printed
in a new line now if you want all the
characters to be printed in the same
line of course you can have your and
attribute here print that and so the
string is printed in the same line but
again it was printed one by one that is
one character at a time now it strings
there's a concept called slicing so
slicing is extracting a part of the
string right now we saw how you can
extract exactly one character from a
string now what if you want to extract
say the first five characters of your
string STG so this is where slicing
comes in and it's a very simple concept
all you have to do is you give you a
variable name your string variable name
and within your square braces as
previously you mentioned that one index
this thing will mention the two indexes
and a colon in between so I've worn my
first five characters so I'll start from
zero index and go up til five with a
colon in between them so let's print
this and as you see I got my first five
characters of the string STG now when
you starting from the beginning of your
string you can avoid giving this first
index what I mean is you can just put in
your variable name and instead of having
zero to five here you can just ignore
the zero so Python assumes that your
first index is zero when you just skip
it when we print this you see both the
results are the same now let's say I
want to extract all the characters from
the fifth index up to the end of the
string in this case I can just print off
STG and within the square braces since
we want all the characters starting from
the fifth index a false index would be 5
: and since we want every character till
the end of the string to be extracted we
can leave the second index space empty
so when you know this the interpreter
assumes that your end index is basically
e to the end of the string so let's run
this and as you see here all elements
from the 5th index up to the end of the
string has been extracted now suppose
you want to extract some elements from
in between the string so in this case it
is compulsory that you must enter both
your beginning and your end index so say
print STG off and suppose I want to
extract all characters from the second
index up till the 4th index so in this
case my first index would be 2 because I
want to start extracting from my second
index position and my end index would be
5 and not 4 so the reason here is that
the element at
and in next position is always excluded
so if you put five here as your end
index then all the characters till the
fourth index position would be extracted
and if I enter four here then all the
elements leak third index position would
be extracted let me print this too so a
last output it's the elements in the
second third and the fourth index
position now python has a number of
inbuilt methods which makes it easy and
efficient to deal with the string
datatype now there are a large number of
such methods and of course we don't have
the time to go through all of them so
we'll go through some of the most
commonly used ones let's start by
creating a string so my string is
welcome to simply learn now the first
method we look at is to print an entire
string in uppercase so print your
variable name period upper so all the
inbuilt methods this is how they are
called
you have your variable name your string
variable name followed by a period and
then your method name and the
parenthesis so some of the methods
require some parameters to be passed
within it and some of the methods do not
so the upper method prints our string in
uppercase now you must remember that
these methods do not change the value of
the original string they just return a
new string so SC g dot upper let's print
that and our entire string is printed in
uppercase in the similar manner we have
a method to print a string in lowercase
- there you go
that's just dot lower so here our entire
strings in lower case entire string is
printed in uppercase now initially we
saw that if you want to extract a
particular character at certain location
you can just give the location index and
the character is extracted now what if
you want to find out the index of a
particular character in that
case we have a method called find find
returns the index of the first
occurrence of the character so the
syntax is very similar your variable
name dot find now for this method you
need a parameter passed and the
parameter of course is the character
whose index we want to find out so
suppose I want to find the index of the
character capital S so a character
capital S is at the eleventh position
with the positioning or the index
starting from 0 onwards
now this another function which is
exactly similar to find which is the
index function and the index function to
does the same thing it returns the index
of the character that you pass within
the brackets so if I see s here both of
them return the index which is 11 now
these methods they give the index of the
first occurrence of this character since
we only have one capital S it's obvious
it's giving the index of this particular
character now if I say n as you can see
our string it has an L here and one here
too so if I give L in these two places
let's run our program you see the index
return is for this L that is our very
first n now let's look at another
inbuilt method for Strings which is the
split function so what the split
function does is it it converts your
string to a list and it does this based
on a delimiter that we pass as a
parameter to the method if I say print
off STG dot split and within these
brackets I'll pass the parameter now if
you look at our string here it's a
sentence or a phrase where each word is
separated by a space so if we want each
word to be a separate element of the
list then what's separating these words
is the space and that would be a
delimiter here so within quotes I pass
space let's run this if you notice the
last
output that we got here this is a list
and the elements of this list are the
words in our stream so if we observe the
return value of these methods you'll
notice that the first to return a string
these two they return an integer or the
index number and the last one that we
executed that is a split method that
returns a list now often this is a very
useful method so what you do is you
store the return value of this method in
a variable say X equal to SC G dot split
off and then you can utilize this list
in doing multiple functions in this case
I have nothing to do with X I'm just
printing it but when you start coding
you'll find that the split function
comes very handy now what if you want to
replace a certain part of your string
for this we have the replace method so
you have STG dot
replace now within the brackets you have
two parameters to pass the first
parameter is that part of the string
that is to be replaced so suppose I want
to replace the words simply learn in my
string so that will be my first
parameter and my second parameter is
what I want to replace this particular
part of the string by so I want my
string to say welcome to Python tutorial
instead of welcome to simply learn so
I'll replace simply learn with Python
tutorial let me print that out so this
method 2 will return a string it will
not change our original string none of
these methods do that yeah so as you can
see here it's returned welcome to Python
tutorial instead of welcome to simply
learn now python has another data type
called Topol if you would have gone
through a previous video on variables we
introduced tuples there so tuples are a
lot like lists except they're immutable
now our next method is the R
partition method so our partition method
is a lot like the split method but here
it creates a double so it returns a
double and the stuff will always has
three elements let's start writing this
method and then I'll explain to you how
it works
so STG dot our partition and within the
brackets you enter that one part of the
string based on which you'll create this
partition now if I pass within my
brackets the string space to space what
this will do is my tuple always has to
have three elements so if you look at
the original string this part here that
is a space to space forms the middle
element of my double that is the second
element of my double everything before
this part that is the entire welcome
word will become the first element of my
double and everything after this part
which is the work simply learn becomes
the third element of my double so I
print this out and you can see how it
looks like so as you see here our
partition returned a tuple and split
here this returned a list so our tuples
second element is what we passed within
our brackets and the other two elements
are everything before and after it
respectively so these are some of the
basic and commonly used inbuilt methods
with strings in Python now let's move on
to concatenate in strings so string
concatenation are pretty simple with
Python see you have two strings scg one
which holds good and SDG two which holds
morning now using these two strings you
want to create a third string which
holds good morning so what I can do is I
will just have a variable STG and that
will be equal to s T G 1 plus now I need
a space between these two words
so plus space which will be inserted
within quotes because at the end it's
all a string again
the plus and our next variable which is
STG - and then I'll print STD out so you
can see here scg printed out good
morning good from s DG 1 and morning
from s DG 2 now if you have no
operations to be done with the
concatenation of two strings that is you
do not need this third variable at all
you can directly put this concatenation
part within a print statement like that
it's exactly the same now things get
slightly more complicated when you have
a number of strings to add now let's say
I have three strings so STG one which
holds hey STG two which holds there and
su 3 which holds all now what I wore my
new string to have this hey there come
up all followed by an exclamation now
this could be done in the previous way
we can have the plus symbol to add the
various strings including the space the
comma and everything inserted within
quotes but that gets a little messy when
you have a number of variables to add
and other extra strings to be added in
between so here is where we use the
format inbuilt function for Strings so
what we're going to do here so we'll
have a fourth readable STG now I'll just
write down the format first and then
I'll explain it to you
okay
so how this works is first you have to
give a format for your string so that is
inserted within double quotes now these
places here the curly braces they are
called placeholders wherever the curly
braces are placed that is exactly where
the respective string from your format
function will go to that is our first
placeholder will be replaced by the
value of s tg1 a second place holder
will be replaced by the value of s dg2
and a third place holder here would be
replaced by the value of s dg3 and
everything that is in between is printed
exactly the same so here I have inserted
a space the space will be printed
exactly as it is in the same location
that I have given the comma and the
space here too will be printed exactly
the same way and the exclamation would
be printed the same - so at first you
give a string within which you have
placeholders for these strings that
already exist
followed by dot and then the format
function to which you pass the variables
that take the place of these
placeholders so now let's print out STG
and as you see STG holds exactly what we
wanted hey there comma space on
exclamation so now that we have gone
through the various basics of strings we
looked at some of the inbuilt methods
for strings the various ways in which we
can store strings now finally let's go
to a demo where we'll have a logic based
program to deal with strings so in this
particular program we will reverse each
word of your string so let's see your
string is what a great day
the program should return ta HW a t AE r
g and why ad so entire string is not
reversed only each word in the string
needs to be reversed so let's begin
first thing we take the input
from the user for what string the user
would like to reverse so the input
method enter a sentence okay so the
input method always returns a string so
even if the user enters numbers it will
be returned as a string now we'll have a
temp variable which will hold the
reverse of each word and initially the
temp variable is empty we'll also have
another variable which is re v that is
basically short for reverse which will
hold a final string which has the
reversed words within it now as we know
the simplest way to iterate over a
string is the for loop and for that we
use the for loop so for I in scg now a
strategy is that every time we find a
space we know that the next character is
going to be a start of a word so that is
where we need to start reversing so
we'll check if I is a space if it is a
space
we'll just keep to the next character if
not then we put these into a temp
variable but in the reverse order so the
first thing we do is we'll see if I is
not equal to space and if I is not equal
to space then we'll add I to the temp
variable so let's assume a string here
is hey there so in that case stem is
initially empty the first character that
goes into temprid be edge the second
character that I holes is e so e again
is not equal to space so it would come
inside this if statement and now he
would be added to temp but instead of
writing temp plus IV right I plus them
so that E is added before edge so in
that way we can form the reverse of the
word so we do that here and if I is
equal to space which comes under the
else statement in that case we know that
this particular letter I is not a part
of
pennyworth so we do not need to add to
any reverse of the word in fact we
probably have a word which is already
reversed so what I mean to say is once
again let's write welcome to simply
learn so here suppose I is at this
particular location so I is a space so
if it is a space that means temp already
holds the reverse of welcome so first we
need to put the stem or this reversed
word into a final string which is Rev so
Rev equal to r f+ temp and now we'll
prepare them for our next word which is
two so we'll clear them and that is it
and once you exit the for loop will
print the value of Rev which is a final
string so we'll explain this once again
we'll take the input from the user we
are creating two variables temp and ref
temp will hold the reverse of every word
and Rev will hold a final string which
contains the reverse of every word now
fall is here to iterate over our input
string which is STG now every time I
will take a character from the string
will check if I is not equal to space so
if I is not equal to space that means I
is a part of some word and we need to
reverse this word so we'll add this to
temp but we'll write I plus them instead
of 10 plus I so that I is put before
whatever temp is holding right now and
in this way we can form the reverse of
the word and if I is space which is
under L statement in that case we know
that I is not part of any word so we do
not need to add it to the reverse of
something in fact a temp probably
already has a reversed word so we'll add
this reversed word to our final string
which is left and then we'll clear temp
so that it can hold the reverse for the
next word and then I moves on to the
next element of our string and the same
procedure continues now once that's done
you print Rev let's
on this program and my input string is
welcome to simply learn so now look at
the output here there are actually two
words which are reversed there's two and
this is welcome but there is no space in
between them that is something simple to
debug we miss out adding a space in
between Rev and temp
so we'll do that but the second problem
with this output is the word simply
alone is missing completely now this is
because we are adding Tim to a final
string only when we find a space so the
first time welcome was reversed
completely then I was pointing to the
space and that is when welcome was added
to Rev which is a final string similarly
when I came to this location and it
entered the else statement that is when
Tim which was holding the reverse of two
was added to Rev but there's no space
after simply learn the simply loan was
reversed and it was stored in them but
it was never added to rev so to correct
this what we do is every time we take an
input from the user will immediately add
a space to the end of the string so STG
equal to s TG + space let's run the
program now and there you go we have the
reverse of every word of our string and
with that we come to an end of a
tutorial on strings in Python if you
have any doubts regarding this please
post them in the comment section below
and we'll definitely get back to you if
you like the video please hit the like
button also subscribe to our channel if
you have not yet as we have a lot more
great videos coming up for you so keep
practicing see you all next time
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos de nerd up and get certified
click here